[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend auf
den tag drei monate ist es her dass in
kiew die ersten bomben einschlugen und
in deutschland weltbilder in sich
zusammenfielen andere waren bekanntlich
etwas weniger überrascht dass das regime
und premier putin tatsächlich sein
nachbarland über feld und es sich brutal
einzuverleiben und zigtausende tote in
kauf nimmt auf unter den eigenen
soldaten
seitdem ist in diesen drei monaten ja
viel geschehen auch vieles womit putin
offenkundig nicht gerechnet hatte wie
scharf europäer und amerikaner reagieren
und vor allem wie stark die ukraine ihr
land verteidigen derzeit konzentrieren
sich die kämpfe auf den don was im osten
henry bestreitest unser reporter in der
ukraine dem unkraut lassen sie im libro
keine chance auch wenn seit 90 tagen
krieg ist und rauchwolken am ufer
gegenüber zeigen die einschläge
russische raketen kommen näher zum
alltag zwischen improvisierten
verteidigungs wellen und panzersperren
gehört die hilfe für kämpfer an der
front manchmal auch sehr improvisiert
wie dieses periskop zum spielen aus der
deckung
das haben wir mit dem 3d drucker selbst
entworfen dann dieses rohr besorgt und
alles zusammen geschraubt und dann die
beiden spiegel eingebaut
vor dem krieg hat maria musik studiert
in rackith geige und klavier statt für
das abschlusskonzert zu üben unterstützt
sie jetzt schon drei monate lang
soldaten von denen nach ukrainischen
angaben im donnerstag über 100 getötet
werden
die nächsten kriegswochen werden
schwierig das muss uns ganz klar sein
aber es gibt auch keine alternative zum
kämpfen
auch russland macht keinerlei anstalten
einzulenken
hochglanzbilder des moskauer
verteidigungsministeriums
suggerieren überlegenheit noch den
britische geheimdienste inzwischen von
fast 30.000 gefallenen russischen
soldaten aus in den wirren des krieges
hat er versucht eine neue atom
katastrophe in der ukraine zu verhindern
bewaffnete soldaten und panzer im
atomkraftwerk tschernobyl setzten
sicherheitsingenieur valerie simpson auf
unter dauerstress als die russen nach 35
tagen endlich abrücken plünderten sie
vorher noch die büros
um eine dreiviertelstunde lang haben sie
alles zusammengerafft was ihnen in die
finger fiel sogar die persönlichen dinge
des personals sie haben nagelneue
ersatzreifen ihrer lastwagen
weggeschmissen und platz für ihre beute
zu schaffen
russlands angriff auf die ukraine das
schreckliche leid der zivilbevölkerung
mit laut vereinten nationen bislang fast
4000 toten das alles trägt bei zu einem
wachsenden ukrainischen bewusstsein nach
drei monaten krieg steht auch maria fest
zur ukraine
obwohl sie selbst russische wurzeln hat
das verhältnis zur familie hat sich
verändert ja am anfang war es schwer wir
wussten selber nicht was da vor sich
geht wir haben viel diskutiert
im nitro bemühen sie sich um einen
normalen alltag die menschen hier hoffen
dass der krieg nicht doch noch über den
fluss kommt
der krieg ist natürlich auch das
beherrschende thema auf dem
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos zu den
prominenten gästen gehörte dort heute eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen mit ihr habe ich vorhin ein
gespräch geführt doch zunächst berichtet
susanne biedenkopf aus davos
blumenstadt vereister straßen bewegt
euch so die devise im frühling in davos
für die gesundheit das klima und
überhaupt tut es gut wenigstens die
eigenen schritte zu lenken in dieser
welt voll durcheinander der krieg in der
ukraine und die folgen bestimmen auch an
diesem tag den ton und die fragen was
sind uns unsere werte wert und was die
geschäfte
überraschende worte von einem der sich
stets stark machte für eine
globalisierte wirtschaft
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
warnt vor den folgen der abhängigkeit
von autoritären regimes nicht nur in
energiefragen
wir müssen anerkennen dass unsere
wirtschaftlichen entscheidungen auch
auswirkungen auf unsere sicherheit haben
freiheit ist wichtiger als freihandel
der schutz unserer werte ist wichtiger
als
profiteur war los
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen denkt an den aufbau des
zerstörten landes die gesammelten gelder
müssen koordiniert und gesteuert werden
dafür schlägt sie eine europäische
plattform vor der plattform in weiz
gelobte plattform ist offen für beiträge
aus aller welt von jedem land dem an der
zukunft der ukraine gelegen ist vom
internationalen
finanzinstitutionen und vom privatsektor
wir brauchen alle mann an bord
alle mann an bord das gilt was die
europäische finanzierung betrifft nicht
für den deutschen finanzminister
gemeinsamen schulden erteilte er aus
brüssel eine absage
eine vergemeinschaftung
eines
schuldenfinanzierten instruments das
dann als zuschuss vergeben wird also
next generation eu fortsetzung das ist
für uns ordnungspolitisch ausgeschlossen
für den chef des chemiekonzerns bayer
ist die hilfe für die ukraine schon
jetzt konkret
kurzfristig geht es zunächst einmal
darum unsere 700 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter ihre familien in der ukraine
zu unterstützen sie letztendlich weiter
zu beschäftigen und vor allen dingen
auch mit den massiven probleme mit denen
sie jeden tag zu kämpfen haben zu
unterstützen in einem zweiten schritt
geht es darum unsere infrastruktur die
wir heute in der ukraine haben die
teilweise beschädigt ist wieder
aufzubauen und danach natürlich mit dem
wiederaufbau in der ukraine auch weiter
zu expandieren und dazu werden wir die
nötigen investments dann auch zur
verfügung stellen
am abend in davos ein
solidaritätskonzert für die ukraine und
der wunsch dass die welt eines tages
doch wieder heller wird
und die eu kommissionspräsidenten ist
uns aus davos zugeschaltet guttenberg
frau von der leyen
guten namen von slomka wir hatten
gestern den deutschen
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck im
gespräch der war sehr optimistisch was
das öl embargo angeht der sagte er
erwartet da einen durchbruch in wenigen
tagen können sie diesen optimismus
bestätigen
weil wir hart arbeiten hart daran dass
wir dieses öl embargo auch umsetzen
können wir haben 12 mitgliedsstaaten die
echte technische probleme haben nämlich
keine zugang zum zur küste deshalb also
kein öl über den seeweg bekommen können
mit den arbeiten wir daran wie können
wir eigentlich dann das pipeline gas
ersetzen durch eine andere pipeline wie
können wir ihrer ferien aufrüsten oder
umrüsten für das neue andere öl und wie
können wir mehr investieren in
erneuerbare energien und diese
diskussion das ist ja technisch was ich
jetzt auch gerade sagen diese nationen
die laufen jetzt im augenblick aber geht
es nur um technisches also der
litauische außenminister der verliert
langsam mit dem mitgliedsland ungarn die
geduld und sagt ungarn die halten uns
hier eigentlich wie in eine geisel gibt
es einen wirklichen um technische
probleme
wer ist ja eines der mitgliedsländer
über das siekaczek mit dem es
schwierigkeiten gibt
es sind objektiv diese schwierigkeiten
vorhanden ohne zweifel dann gibt es
weitere diskussionen natürlich über die
höhe der investition investition und
hier ist wichtig dass die anderen 26
mitgliedstaaten da auch sehen dass es
fair zugeht wir wollen investieren in
die erneuerbaren energien damit die
energie ersetzen die wir sonst bisher
aus russland bekommen haben aber es muss
für alle fair zugehen ein großes thema
ist auch der wiederaufbau der ukraine
moment herrscht dort noch dieser
furchtbaren krieg aber die ukrainer
selbst sprechen ja auch schon über über
im wiederaufbau und wie das
funktionieren soll man hat der deutsche
finanzminister christian lindner gesagt
ja wiederaufbau jahr aber mit
gemeinschaftsschulden der eu da ist ja
gar nicht für was eigentlich den
vorschlag den sie gemacht haben vom
tisch fegt oder
ich habe eine plattform vorgeschlagen wo
wir erst mal diese ganzen die aktiven
bündeln die es jetzt weltweit schon gibt
eine plattform die geleitet wird von der
ukraine selbe und der europäischen
kommission
denn wir wollen nicht nur investitionen
und die müssen massiv sein sondern wir
wollen dass auch koppeln gleich mit den
reformen die für dieses land auch
notwendig sind der aufbau der verwaltung
der kampf gegen die korruption
die wirtschaft voranbringen und da ist
es wichtig dass diese vielen initiativen
zb oecd world bank aber eben auch die
europäische union oder andere wie unsere
amerikanischen freunde dass wir alle
zusammen auf dieser plattform
investieren und es gleichzeitig aber
auch darüber einigen das ganz klare
formen in dem land auch stattfinden
müssen das ebnet übrigens dann auch den
weg der ukraine in die europäische union
das ist schön dass wir nämlich die
nächste frage gewesen das sind jetzt
sozusagen diese brücke schon bauen
werden sie den kandidatenstatus im juni
verkünden als kommissionspräsidentin
wir sind noch mitten in der analyse mir
ist wichtig noch mal deutlich zu machen
beim kandidatenstatus das ist kein
freifahrtschein und es gibt auch keine
abkürzungen sondern es geht darum im
beitrittsprozess dass man bestimmte
standards erfüllt die wir alle be-
erfüllen müssen in der europäischen
union also wirtschaftlich politisch
rechtsstaatlich zum beispiel aber es
hängt sehr stark davon ab wie schnell
ein land ist und wie es sich engagiert
wir haben beispiele von ländern die
diesen beitrittsprozess in zwei drei
jahren geschafft haben zum beispiel die
slowakei weil sie sich enorm
zusammengerissen hat große schritte nach
wie vor von der leyen es geht halt auch
schnell so weit war es geht ja jetzt
erst mal um diesen um diesen kameraden
status da er sagte noch nichts darüber
aus wann ist man dann wirklich mitglied
das ist ja auch eine politische geste
sie waren sehr dafür daran den ukrainern
diesen diese hoffnung zu erfüllen können
sie sich dann nicht konkreter äußern ob
sie daran festhalten sie mir auch den
ukrainern geholfen diese dicken bücher
auszufüllen die man ausfüllen muss um
sich zu bewerben
richtig und dieser prozess wird erst
abgeschlossen sein der analyse wie weit
ist das land was kann ich empfehlen und
vor allen dingen eine fundierte
grundlage warum ich das empfehle mehr
oder minder mitte juni wird das der fall
also wir müssen nicht mehr lange darauf
warten mir ist aber auch wichtig noch
einmal zu betonen man kann schnell sein
wie ich eben sagte mit der slowakei aber
ein beitrittskandidat kann auch jahre
und jahrzehnte warten wenn man langsam
ist und nicht vorankommt das heißt
dieser prozess ist wirklich der kug
danach ließ die qualität des
fortschrittes und es liegt am land
selber und diese chance wollen wir die
ukraine geben wirklich nach vorne zu
kommen ein großes thema jetzt auch in
der groß waren die warenlieferungen die
von russland blockiert werden die also
nicht aus der ukraine herauskommen die
dort in den häfen blockiert sind gibt es
da irgendeine konkrete lösung ich meine
die westlichen staaten werden jetzt
nicht anfangen oder deshalb die bomben
und der setzte bombardieren um dort
russische stellung und zu vernichten
sind es muss ja irgendein anderer
lösungen geben gibt es da irgendeine
hoffnung dass man diesen weizen aus der
ukraine rausbekommt
die situation ist dramatisch das sind 20
millionen tonnen weizen die jetzt fest
sitzen in der ukraine russland
bombardiert systematisch die
die lagerhäuser mit dem weizen es ist
katastrophal weil die welt braucht
diesen weizen und gerade die ärmsten
länder der welt sind darauf angewiesen
wir versuchen jetzt alles den weizen an
dass auf anderen wegen rauszubekommen
das heißt über die straße über
züge das ist natürlich alles nicht so
effizient wie wenn man den seeweg wählen
könnte es versuchen einige das gespräch
und das ist gut zu führen mit russland
ob es nicht eine lösung gibt einen
korridor im schwarzen meer zu schaffen
das ist noch ganz am anfang aber wir
müssen dieses gespräch führen es geht
darum wirklich schwere hungersnöte in
den ländern die am meisten betroffen
sind und am empfindlichsten und am
verletzlichsten sind zu vermeiden die
pro von der leyen danke für das gespräch
danke ihnen
was die ukraine ihren weizen nicht
exportieren kann reist in der tat eine
gewaltige lücke dennoch ließen sich die
ausfälle theoretisch kompensieren wenn
andere länder einspringen einige
hoffnungen lagen auf indien das
eigentlich ein großer getreide produzent
ist und die inder hatten auch durchaus
interesse als exporteur neue märkte zu
erobern doch das hat sich schlagartig
geändert seitdem klar ist dass indien in
dieser saison nicht so ernten kann wie
erhofft das land leidet unter einer
rekordhitze und dürre stichwort
klimawandel hinzu kommen die
preissteigerungen die auch in indien zu
spüren sind unser hat die regierung
jetzt einen exportstopp verhängt aus
angst sonst die eigene bevölkerung nicht
mehr satt zu bekommen
normen odenthal berichtet
partner ist eine von zig millionen
indiens ärmste die ständig vom hunger
bedroht sind und nur mit hilfe des
staatlichen ernährungsprogramms
überlegen können jeden monat kann sich
sattler hier kostenlos weizen abholen in
der pandemie moderation erhöht auf acht
kilo pro person zu hause bhatia partys
dass es das tägliche brot für die ganze
familie
wir brauchen das günstige getreide wenn
wir das nicht hätten wüsste ich nicht
wie ich meine kinder ernähren sollte sie
würden hungert
1,3 milliarden menschen leben in indien
alle müssen essen alle brauchen brot
alle brauchen weizen
indiens landwirtschaft ist also wichtig
bauern wie ram gopal ernähren das land
ich habe fünf hektar felder darauf baue
ich weizen an sonst habe ich nur ein
paar kühe aber das land ist gut wir
haben reiche ernten nur in diesem jahr
nicht die hohen temperaturen haben alles
versucht
kahle felder abgeerntet jetzt schon viel
zu früh die bauern mussten den weizen
reinholen bevor er vollends vertrocknet
die wochenlange hitzewelle wie es auch
am pokal keine wahlen
seht euch das an größer sind die
weizenkörner nicht in anderen jahren
wäre das die schlechteste qualität jetzt
ist es das beste was ich habe wegen der
hitze habe ich auf meinen feldern 50
prozent weniger ertrag
einbußen überall praktisch alles was
geerntet wird landet ihr in staatlichen
lagern indien wappnet sich in einem land
in dem ohnehin viele hungern droht die
missernte die lage zu verschärfen
deshalb sagt der start der weizen bleibt
im land exportverbot
es ist doch richtig dass wir den weizen
nicht mehr exportieren die bestände
könnten knapp werden dann hätten wir
nichts für uns und müssen selbst weizen
im ausland kaufen
vor ein paar wochen noch hatte die
regierung andere pläne vollmundig
verkündet indien würde die welt ernähren
einspringen für die ukraine dessen
riesige weizenproduktion dem krieg zum
opfer fällt dann aber kam die hitze und
die regierung bekam kalte füße
hier stehen einige wichtige wahlen an
und es hat sich gezeigt dass man mit
einem ernährungsprogramm viel
wählerstimmen der ärmeren bevölkerung
gewinnen kann deshalb braucht die
regierungspartei volle getreidelager
dafür und das ist schlecht zerstört sie
indiens glaubwürdigkeit in der welt
ausnahmen sollen möglich bleiben und
werden dann marketinggerecht inszeniert
hier gehen mit großem tamtam 2000 tonnen
weizen auf die fahrt nach afghanistan
hunger ist ein globales phänomen indien
möchte sich nicht nachsagen lassen dass
es im kampf dagegen allein an sich denkt
das thema vertieft nachher im
heute-journal update noch unter narkose
mit dem deutschland-chef des
welternährungsprogramms der vereinten
nationen jetzt heinz wolf mit den
nachrichten die fälle von affen pocken
häufen sich in europa gibt es mehr als
100 in deutschland mindestens acht
bestätigte infektionen
das robert-koch-institut empfiehlt nun
eine isolation von mindestens 21 tagen
um das ausbruchsgeschehen in den griff
zu bekommen und dass gesundheitsminister
lauterbach betonte es handle sich nicht
um den beginn einer neuen pandemie man
müsse offen trocken aber ernst nehmen
die virus erkrankung tritt vor allem in
west- und zentralafrika
auf und nur selten anderenorts was die
derzeitigen ausbrüche ungewöhnlich macht
die ständige impfkommission hat eine
neue empfehlung für corona impfungen von
fünf bis elfjährigen herausgegeben sie
gilt nun nicht mehr nur für bestimmte
gruppen wie vor erkrankte sondern
generell die impfempfehlung werde
vorsorglich ausgesprochen weil ein
erneuter anstieg von corona infektionen
im herbst beziehungsweise winter zu
erwarten sei
sowohl in schleswig holstein als auch in
nordrhein westfalen gab es heute
schwarz- grüne gespräche jeweils über
die möglichkeit eine koalitionsregierung
zu bilden in nordrhein westfalen kam
ministerpräsident wüst von der cdu und
grünen landeschefin neubauer mit ihren
stationen seiner ersten sondierungsrunde
zusammenhang in schleswig holstein ist
man schon weiter nach den gesprächen von
cdu-ministerpräsident günther und den
grünen spitzenkandidatinnen heinold und
touré beschlossen die grünen am abend
koalitionsverhandlungen aufzunehmen
im wahlprüfungsausschuss des bundestages
ging es heute um die bundestagswahl vom
vergangenen september konkret um den
vorwurf von wahl fehlern in berliner
bezirken bundeswahlleiter thiel
plädierte für eine teilweise
wahlwiederholung dort mit einer
entscheidung darüber ist nach angaben
der ausschussvorsitzenden nicht vor der
parlamentarischen sommerpause zu rechnen
altkanzler schröder hat nach eigenen
angaben auf die nominierung für den
aufsichtsrat des russischen
staatskonzerns gazprom verzichtet und
zwar schon vor längerer zeit er
reagierte damit auf berichte dass der
energiekonzern seine nominierung für ein
aufsichtsratsmandat
nochmals bekräftigt habe schröder hatte
vergangene woche seinen posten im
aufsichtsrat von rosneft einem anderen
russischen energiekonzern aufgegeben
nach vorwürfen wegen anhaltend enger
verbindungen nach russland
ungarns ministerpräsident orban hat
wegen des ukraine krieges den notstand
erklärt wie man mit halte solle ungarn
so vor den wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
geschützt werden dass ein kabinett
benötige den handlungsspielraum um rasch
reagieren zu können unter dem notstand
ist es möglich per dekret zu regieren
der derzeit in ungarn geltende
gesundheitsnotstand wegen der korona
pandemie läuft ende des monats aus
auch bei einem treffen der
regierungschefs japans australiens
indiens und der usa-präsident beiden
russlands angriff auf das land als
globales problem bezeichnet in tokio
forderte biden zudem mehr unterstützung
für die ukraine einen ähnlichen konflikt
im indopazifik zu verhindern ist
erklärtes ziel der sogenannten quads
staaten ohne china direkt zu nennen ist
es in einer gemeinsamen erklärung
einseitige maßnahmen die die spannungen
in der region erhöht und lehne man ab
nicht dass irgendwann china taiwan
angreift und viele wieder überrascht
sind dass die volksrepublik nicht nur
nach innen ein aggressiver startest dass
das mit wandel durch handel dort auch
nicht funktioniert hat diese erkenntnis
setzt sich im westen ja auch eher
langsam durch fast schon philosophisch
wurde da heute nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg als er in davos sagte
freiheit sei wichtiger als freihandel
das ist in der region im nordwesten
chinas internierungslager für die
muslimische minderheit der uiguren gibt
ist schon länger bekannt doch jetzt
wurde erstmals
umfangreiches material gelegt und
internationalen medien wie der bbc und
dem spiegel zugespielt sie haben die
dokumente geprüft und nun veröffentlicht
pofalla bericht
sie schauen uns an tausendfach und
zwingen uns nicht wegzuschauen die
gefangenen der umerziehungslager haben
ein gesicht bekommen sie sind weg
gesperrt wegen ihres glaubens für das
studium religiöser schriften
34 jahre gefängnis das beweisen diese
dokumente die daten belegen halt
wirklich ohne jegliche zweifel
die gefängnis artigen natur dieser
umerziehungslager durch die die
dokumente die er genau sagen wie die
lage zu beobachten sind welche waffen
die polizei benutzt adrian sense hat die
daten anonym zugespielt bekommen er
forscht seit jahren zum schicksal der
uiguren es sind grausame bilder die
zeigen wie brutal chinas machthaber die
uiguren unterdrücken die bilder stammen
von 2018 aus einem umerziehungslager in
china sie belegen die massen
internierung 'nen und kulturelle
vernichtung der muslimischen minderheit
und sie belegen dass die befehle vom
präsidenten selbst kommen skijumping
selber ordnet an dass also mehr
polizisten mehr polizeiwachen für lager
und gefängnisse eingestellt werden
müssen in china soll es mehr als 300
lager geben eine million menschen die
muslimischen minderheiten angehören soll
china in den letzten jahren interniert
haben die dokumente gäben den opfern ein
gesicht
die internationale gemeinschaft hat die
moralische verpflichtung diesen
völkermord zu stoppen es gibt keinen
grund mehr zu schweigen denn hier sieht
die neue beweise vor
wir sind selbst
2021 nach tianjin gereist qashqai ist
die hochburg der uiguren
die polizei steht an jeder ecke
hier treffen drei mädchen fast beiläufig
erzählen sie uns von umerziehungslager
ohne das wort in den mund zu nehmen
es ist ein ort zum lernen viele menschen
sind dort deswegen sagen manche uiguren
dass sie nicht frei sind von einigen von
uns wurden papa mama dorthin gebracht
heute traf die un
menschenrechtskommissarin mit dem
chinesischen außenminister zusammen kein
wort bisher von ihr zu den vorwürfen
stattdessen spricht peking von lügen
dies ist der letzte versuch einer
antichinesischen
verleumdungskampagne es ist immer das
gleiche
aber lügen werden die welt nicht
täuschen
außenministerin baerbock fordert nun
aufklärung
es ist für mich wichtig dass diese
vorwürfe von chinesischer seite die seit
langem bekannt sind dass ich dazu
positioniert wird
china will nicht dass die welt diese
bilder sieht china will dass wir
wegschauen während wir die dokumente
abfilmen verschwindet die seite wir
vermuten der chinesische staat steckt
dahinter
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit wirtschaft
es fehlt an fachkräften in immer mehr
deutschen unternehmen die staatliche
förderbank kfw spricht nach daten für
den april von einem neuen höhepunkt beim
fachkräftemangel
valerie haller was bedeutet dass welche
folgen hat es wenn fachkräfte fehlen
weitreichende folgen natürlich brands
der fachkräftemangel einzelne
unternehmen aus aufträge bleiben liegen
er gefährdet aber auch große projekte
die energie und verkehrswende die
digitalisierung und die stärkung des
pflegesystems all das ist laut
wirtschaftsforschern nur zu stemmen wenn
mehr gut ausgebildete leute nachkommen
und nicht nur jene mit abgeschlossenem
studium im april hat der
fachkräftemangel einen neuen rekord
erreicht spitzenreiter war erneut der
dienstleistungssektor darunter besonders
gastronomie und tourismus stark
betroffen auch verarbeitendes gewerbe
bau und handel unterm strich klagt
nahezu die hälfte der befragten
unternehmen über fehlendes fachpersonal
das zeigt sich auch an deutschlands
größtem flughafen dort wird zwar wieder
eingestellt dennoch fehlt es an
mitarbeitern in frankfurt die folge sind
mitunter lange wartezeiten auf der
hauptversammlung entschuldigte sich
fraport chef schulte flüge müssten
verschoben oder auch ganz gestrichen
werden zu wenig beschäftigte gibt es
auch bei den fluggesellschaften die
pilotengewerkschaft cockpit rechnet für
den sommer mit massiven flugausfällen
gründe für den fachkräftemangel gibt es
viele demografischer wandel zu wenig
azubis abhilfe schaffen könnte
wirtschaftsforschern zufolge zuwanderung
und eine aufwertung der beruflichen
ausbildung valerie haller vielen dank
zur fußball bundesliga und zwei
trainerwechseln der vfl wolfsburg hat
niko kovac als neuen chefcoach
vorgestellt und offenheim wird künftig
von andré breitenreiter trainiert bei
der eishockey wm hat die deutsche
nationalmannschaft ihr letztes
vorrundenspiel gegen die schweiz mit 3 2
4 verloren durch den treffer von
matthias plachta zum 3 3 rettete sich
deutschland ins penalty schießen da
sorgte der schweizer riad für die
entscheidung das deutsche team ist
gruppenzweiter und trifft im
viertelfinale übermorgen auf den
mehrfachen weltmeister tschechien das am
abend gastgeber finnland unterlag
das war's im heute-journal gleich geht's
weiter mit der anstalt und um 0.45 gibt
es dann unser heutigen update mit
gundula gause das morgen auf wiedersehen
wieder sind
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend wie uns der temperatur trend von
berlin zeigt wird es bis zum nächsten
wochenende hier freitag samstag sonntag
noch einmal deutlich kühler da sinken
die temperaturen von um die 20 grad bis
hinab auf um die 15 grad und nachts sind
die temperaturen dann doch meist
einstellige dazu bleibt das wetter
wechselhaft denn wir haben es mit einer
strammen westwind wetterlage zu tun
schon heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen meist auf sechs bis zwölf
grad in der eifel auch teilweise noch
mal etwas kühler dazu ist es meist
trocken heute nacht nur zwischen dem
bayerischen wald und den alpen regnet es
noch mal da kam ja seit dienstagnacht
schon einiges an regen vom himmel so ist
es auch morgen hier im südosten noch
stärker bewölkt dann geht der regen aber
in kurze schauer über und zieht so
langsam ab kurze schauer und zwar auch
gewittrige gibt es noch im küstenumfeld
vor allem gegen nachmittag lebt der
südwestwind ihr wieder deutlich auf
dazwischen gibt es einen streifen und
zwar vom südwesten bis nach brandenburg
in dem ist es doch meist trocken und vor
allem vormittags auch noch recht sonnig
und in genau diesem streifen erreichen
wir morgen temperaturen zwischen 20 und
24 grad ansonsten ist es kühler bei 16
bis 20 grad und das ist auch genau die
temperaturspanne die wir am feiertag
also in christi himmelfahrt erwarten 16
bis 24 grad da ist es dann richtung
süden immer freundlicher und auch
trocken im norden stark bewölkt immer
mal wieder auch schauer und windig aus
west vor allem mit stürmischen böen an
der see auch am freitag und am samstag
geht es wechselhaft und windig weiter
dazu wird es noch mal etwas kühler am
samstag dann nur noch 14 bis 20 grad das
war es von uns ich wünsche ihnen noch
eine schöne woche